You're back!
jane
the old ex-girlfriend
you are not like the other gods earth kill
because i have something worth fighting for
see who you are and take
off your disguise and flick
oh you flick too hard
Welcome back everyone this will be my new thor
love and thunder trailer video they just dropped
a bunch of new footage online so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos the big thing
with this footage that they dropped is that thor
is seeing mjolnir reform for the first time and
i love the way that he's calling to it like a dog
like here mjolnir here mjolnir come here come here
the way they treat the hammer in the mcu is
similar to the way that he treats it in the
comics but the way that the movies explain the
power of the hammer is different from the powers
in the comics it sounds like when he's come back
to new asgard here he sees gorr's army attacking
everyone just trying to kill all the gods that
they can find so he naturally joins the fight
and while he's fighting all of gorr's army here
you can see them kind of in the background here
they're meant to be consumed with some of the same
power that you see coming from the necro sword
that's why they look like these writhing black
monsters all over the place while he's enjoying
himself in the thrill of battle here looking
around new asgard trying to save everyone he sees
mjolnir flying around and just starts freaking
out like oh my god it's back mjolnir is back it
is a big call back to the avengers end game moment
where the hammer actually came to captain america
when it was being called like you saw floating
in the air wondering who it was going to go to
except this time they played like a joke because
thor apparently has never seen mighty thor jane
foster before the look on his face says it all
like what the hell is going on here the way they
play the trailer footage though there's this
big jump in footage like you see her swinging
the hammer around fighting these other people
and he's kind of flabbergasted but then they
immediately jumped to him wearing his full helmet
he's wearing this blue gold armor that looks kind
of like a mixture of his battle armor as well as
the rune king thor armor so it sounds like during
this fight they either finish fighting off course
army and some of them leave or they just defeat
all them and at some point during the battle he
gets a big armor upgrade and then eventually jane
foster's mighty thor takes the helmet off and
he recognizes that it is jane foster like what
jane what's going on here the big change in the
comics is that when mighty thor was introduced
they played it as this big mystery for a long
time and thor didn't know who she really was
but because a couple years ago at the comic con
when they said they were doing this movie they
said they were going to do it based on the mighty
thor plot so we all knew that it was going to be
jane foster thor so i think they just didn't want
to belabor the point like he was going to find out
that it was going to be jane really quickly in
the movie so a lot of you now asking how is it
that mjolnir has reformed what are jane foster's
thor powers like how powerful is she going to be
during the movie compared to the regular version
of thor the way it seems like they're playing in
the movie is because tourism is now a big thing
in new asgard like you see all these funny moments
which is regular tourism going on because now it's
this big attraction as part of that they're doing
the fake play again but this time the fake play
with matt damon's version of loki and you have
luke hemsworth version of thor and now melissa
mccarthy's version of hella they're doing the
fake play based on the plot of thor ragnarok with
hella breaking the hammer making fun of that so it
sounds like we'll watch that during the movie and
then jane foster will just be there at new asgard
for some reason and thinking about mjolnir and
touching the hammer and it sounds like they're
going to say that hello was strong enough to break
the hammer physically but she wasn't strong enough
to break odin's enchantment on it and the whole
twist behind odin's worthy enchantment on the
hammer is that whoever's worthy and wields
the hammer shall have the powers of thor
so it sounds like when gorr's army is getting
ready to attack new asgard or something really
crazy happens in new asgard they need thor but
he's not around and jane foster just happens to be
touching the pieces of mjolnir on this altar here
it sounds like the asgardians just like literally
turned the earth around the pieces of mjolnir
into this shrine and lifted it up that's how
you get around the word of the enchantment as
long as you don't touch the actual pieces you
just touch the earth around the pieces you can
actually lift the hammer up technically but if
you put the hammer in an elevator we still go up
elevator's not worthy i'm gonna miss these little
talks of ours is that whole captain america
joke the elevator's not worthy at the end of
avengers age of ultron the elevator can carry the
hammer but that doesn't make the elevator worthy
she winds up touching the pieces of the hammer
as new asgard is being attacked and that just
activates odin's enchantment the hammer re-forms
again and gives her her armor the only thing we
don't get from any of the trailer footage or
anything that's happened in the mcu yet so far
is to explain what it is that makes jane foster's
thor worthy according to odin's enchantment like
what is it about her that makes her worthy so post
all your theories about that because it's coming
right out of the mighty thor arc the whole thing
with her power level like i said is basically like
a magical copy-paste version of what thor's powers
were at least in the last couple of movies so sort
of a copy-paste work around to giving someone else
the same powers to thor like literally anybody who
wielded the hammer would get the same level of
power but it doesn't make her an actual legit god
the way that thor is supposed to be a legit god in
the mcu it just gives her some of the same types
of powers but it does look like they give her a
couple unique abilities when they're in olympia
fighting zeus's men you see her use the hammer
and it breaks into a bunch of pieces and attacks
a bunch of different people like an area of effect
attack and then reforms back again to the regular
hammer i think they just did that to make it seem
a little more dynamic on screen so that she's not
exactly like the original version of thor like
oh we've seen those powers make it do something
else they have that joke in the trailer about
him not having seen her in like eight years i
think that's meant to be a joke about avengers
end game and the snap because the last real big
movie that they had together was thor the dark
world and that would have been even longer ago
if you think about the five-year time jump so it
sounds like she might have actually been snapped
during the five-year time job because it sounds
like she doesn't think that it's actually been
that long where thor's like no no it's been like
over eight years in the way they're using her
character versus thor in the movie is they're sort
of driving thor to more of a cosmic thor place in
the comics if you haven't read the cosmic thor arc
it's basically thor getting a huge power upgrade
becoming more of an actual guy embracing that
and becoming more of a cosmic figure in the mcu
because of what odin had done because of all
the trials he went through the god level power
he'd obtained thor was actually born a god but he
hasn't really embraced that in the same way like
he just calls himself a god and he is correct
the whole idea during the movie though is that
he's sort of shirking his responsibilities in the
guardians of the galaxy have to kind of inspire
him to go after what it is that he really wants
and find what it is that he really wants like what
do you do if you actually had the powers of a god
in the mcu and that's meant to dovetail with the
whole gorr of the god butcher plot like the gods
don't care about anyone so i'm going to kill all
them with thor being one of the exceptions like no
no i actually care about my subjects i'm actually
trying to help them now so if you read the rune
king thor plot or the cosmic thor plot it's
sort of thor going morton in that direction chris
hemsworth also said that he wanted to stick around
in the mcu for a long time so they're not planning
on getting rid of his version of thor anytime soon
in the way that taika watiti talked about it he
also sounded like the jane foster version of thor
wasn't going to replace him any time soon i think
the way they're going to play it though is that
she'll deal with more earth-based problems like
she will show up again in future movies or future
disney plus projects at some point when they need
a version of thor for smaller earth based problems
and because we just got docker strange 2 they
just teased all the incursions in the post credit
scene the big lead up to secret wars big teaser
for a giant multiverse war kang and everything
that's going on with that doctor strange you
caused an incursion and we're gonna fix it
chris hemsworth's thor will be more worried with
that kind of stuff the same way that he was trying
to learn more about that during the beginning of
thor ragnarok avengers age of ultron but because
they do want to make christian bales gorr the god
butcher seem like a legitimate threat inside the
mcu to all these mcu gods there are many of gods
that we haven't met before yet i think they're
going to wind up killing most of these before
both versions of thor wind up taking him out
the way they tease it in the movie too you see
valkyrie fighting with zeus's lightning bolt r.i.p
zeus it seems like russell crowe zeus kind of
bites it and that's why she's using his lightning
bolt but i think the reason why everything seems
like it's black and white here is because the
powers of the necro sword are basically leeching
life force out of everything around it and that's
why gorr the god butcher seems like he becomes
more and more inhuman throughout the trailer i
don't expect them to do any kind of null backstory
because the whole thing with the necro sword is
they retcon that later on with the venom storyline
to call that the primal symbiote it's always
possible that there's some easter eggs for that or
you could possibly draw some meaning to that but
i don't think that the mcu has plans to do a null
character any time soon i think when we're talking
about the powers of the necro sword in the comics
it'll be more similar to the actual comic book
version in the glory of the god butcher storyline
like this really powerful cosmic artifact that is
capable of killing beings that are that powerful
we'll get a little bit more footage pretty soon
i'll talk more about the difference between
cosmic beings gods because like the celestials
for instance are just cosmic beings who are really
really powerful in doctor strange too we saw the
legitimate living tribunal that's not meant to be
a god that's just a really powerful cosmic figure
but like the living tribunal is meant to be the
most powerful figure almost next to the one above
all who is like the one true god of the entire
marvel multiverse like more powerful than the
beyonders and more powerful than franklin richards
who also got a name drop during doctor strange 2.
we're at that point in the mcu now where they just
start whipping out every op character that you've
ever heard of no matter how obscure from that toy
box but when we're talking about the secret wars
teaser i think they're replacing the beyonders
plot with the kang multiverse war plot like kang
himself will be a much bigger figure in
this version of secret wars in the mcu
they are filming loki season 2 right now maybe
we'll get some kind of post credit scene with
the version of loki from the loki series
everyone post all your reactions and your
theories in the comments below there's a whole
bunch of other trailers and a bunch of marvel
stuff premiering this week make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
that there are going to be a lot of marvel
and a lot of star wars shows happening this
summer of course i'll do videos for everything
everyone click here for my other big thor love
and thunder trailer video and click here for my
brand new black adam trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!